how did a concert film shatter box
office records here's the truth behind
the deal Taylor Swift made with AMC and
how it's paying out Boku bucks for the
pop star Taylor Swift the ays tour made
a reported $92 million domestically in
its opening weekend at the time of this
video the movie's total worldwide box
office earning is more than $178 million
and still climbing that is a tremendous
amount of money for a documentary which
is the film genre the concert movie
technically falls into according to Out
magazine the film broke AMC's record for
first day pre-sales grossing $26 million
in its first 24 hours of being on sale
outperforming the previous recordbreaker
Spider-Man no way home now since it's
been out it's already become the highest
grossing concert movie of all time the
previous King was Justin Bieber Who's
Never Say Never grossed over $99 million
at the global box office this also makes
the aist tour the first concert movie to
make more than $100
million why was it such a big hit well
let's start with the obvious stuff
Taylor Swift is more popular than ever
before in her 17-year career now I'm a
Swifty I'm a
Swifty this certainly fueled The
Sensation that is the AAS tour and the
fervor for this tour has only made Swift
Spotlight shine brighter Swift has
cemented herself as the biggest act in
pop music at this point in time the tour
showed just how large and diverse tailor
Swift's fan bases to sell as many
tickets as it has for the prices they've
gone for her astronomical rise has even
been on the minds of many culture
writers The Guardian Credit Swift's
current ubiquity partly to the new pop
music economy where radio play matters
less than cult-like followings
discussing their favorite artists every
move on Reddit and Tik Tok no matter the
reason the success of the era tour both
the tour and the concert movie happened
because Swift has such an enduring base
of
fans this is the biggest factor in the
success of the eras tour film leftover
demand from the North American leg of
the tour is insatiable Taylor Swift
found a way way to let even more money
pour in while giving fans a second
chance to see the show if they couldn't
make it IRL I didn't get to go to the
tour so I'm excited to see it on the big
screen of course it took a sizable
investment to make the movie 10 to20
million according to Puck but that has
more than paid off for Swift now that
the film has taken control of the box
office the tickets for the ays tour were
so scarce and the resale prices were so
high that it nearly broke the internet
even though this is Taylor Swift we're
talking about we have to take into
account the history of the genre when
talking about expectations while concert
films occasionally turn out to be
cinematic masterpieces like Gimme
Shelter or stop making sense these
aren't always the biggest money makers
in a given year again the highest
grossing concert movie until now was
Justin bers Never Say Never which didn't
crack $100 million in a film landscape
dominated by big studios and streaming
platforms it's been quite a while since
a concert movie has felt like an event
comparing this to the year's biggest
movies for instance Barbie made almost 1
.5 billion Swift's box office takeaway
might not seem like much it's worth
noting though that the budget for a
concert documentary is often 10 times
lower than that of a Hollywood
production reportedly the budget for the
ays tour was $20 million compare that to
say the $200 million budget for killers
of the flower Moon Taylor Swift the eras
tour came to theaters on October 13th
2023 a week with no other major new
movies all the biggest movies at the box
office the week the AAS tour came out
were released the week before the movie
that w W up being its biggest
competition The Exorcist believer even
got out of the way in anticipation of
Swift's dominance Blum House founder
Jason Blum tweeted the decision saying
look what you made me do the Exorcist
believer moves to 10623 # Taylor Wins
even though it came out a week before
the ays tour The Exorcist believer
struggled anyway making $26 million in
its opening weekend word of mouth on
that specific sequel was pretty sour but
even with a better critical response an
R-rated horror movie was never going to
compete compete with the marketing force
that is Taylor Swift outselling killers
of the flower moon in the concert film
second week in theaters is a much more
impressive feat yes Killers is a three
and a half hour R-rated drama but it's
from Goodfellas and The Departed
director Martin scorsi and features the
considerable star power of Robert dairo
and Leonardo DiCaprio This wealth should
come to us yet despite the mostly
glowing reviews killers of the flower
Moon could not compete with the AAS tour
in a normal World tickets to the Aras
tour would have been affordable for
every family to bring their kids if they
wanted to still even if you could afford
tickets other factors got in the way
it's harder to travel with children and
kids have a harder time staying up late
for a long concert AAS tour set lists
were routinely over 3 hours long but if
your kid falls asleep in the middle of a
3-hour movie well it's not as big of a
deal plus it's a lot easier to get
everyone together and file out of a
movie theater than it is a soldout
stadium in the time it would take you to
get to the concert Stadium parking lot
you can make the drive home from the
movie theater or stick around and watch
it again I'm going to go to this movie
at least 13 times young people are a
large part of Taylor Swift's demographic
and the fans who were too young to go to
the show can see the movie with their
parents immediately that makes for a
bunch of tickets sold as evidenced by
the pre-sale numbers that the AOS tour
movie put up there's a strong argument
for the IMAX potential of Taylor Swift
the AOS tour the appeal is obvious you
are already going to the movie not for a
narrative but for the immersive
experience you can only get from being
in a movie theater imax's strengths
enhanced the audiovisual experience of
movies with an emphasis on spectacle the
era tour is all spectacle and a natural
fit for the format on opening weekend
the film was shown on 625 IMAX screens
in 45 markets around the world and iMac
sales accounted for a double digigit
percentage of the opening weekend
pre-sales that is a pretty massive
percentage for a format most movies
don't even get released in more screens
mean more IMAX tickets sold and of
course theaters charge more more for
IMAX tickets which factors into the box
office success of the AAS tour one of
the reasons the AAS tour film got made
was that Taylor Swift took it on as a
personal project according to Puck Swift
and her family put up the reported $20
million that it cost to fund the project
it's not a surprise that they would be
able to make this happen given how much
money they have made on the AOS tour
alone according to Fortune the tour is
set to be the first to ever shatter $1
billion made in ticket sales that's not
even including the $75 hoodies and $45
t-shirts when you're the biggest pop
star in the world it turns out you don't
need something as silly as a movie
studio to make something happen it's not
not
true when it comes to the current
competition we've established that the
AAS tour is blowing everyone out of the
water but let's put that success in
comparison to some of the biggest movies
of the Year Barbie is the biggest hit of
the Year grossing over $1.4 billion at
the worldwide box office its competitor
SL companion Oppenheimer fell just shy
of $1 billion the AOS tour was never
going to hit the heights of these Giants
nor that of the Super Mario Brothers
movie which grossed a mighty $1.36
billion if we look closer to where the
ays tour lands on the list it seems sure
to slip into the top 20 for the year at
$178 million in the first two weeks of
release AAS is looking to overtake
teenage mutant ninja turtles mutant
Mayhem The Equalizer 3 and Insidious the
red door with another weekend of strong
sales the way the deal between Taylor
Swift and AMC Theaters shook out is
another potential reason for its runaway
success AMC agreed to a contract with
swift that earned her 57% of the
earnings on the film and left AMC the
rest according to variety this is a
smaller cut than many major Studios take
Marvel is cited as an example of a
studio that receives closer to 65% of
the box office profits getting an
advantageous deal could be quite a boon
for AMC as it turns out the company has
a hit on its hands they announced Taylor
Swift's movie broke the record Rec for
the most pre-sale tickets sold in one
single day and their CEO is predicting
this will be very lucrative for the
company according to Market Watch shares
of AMC have fallen 73.3% in 2023
although the comparatively successful
summer Hall of Barbie and Oppenheimer
created some cause for optimism Taylor
Swift's concert movie lighting up the
box office may just continue the upward
trend for the movie theater company
there are a couple of key things to
glean from the box office success of
Taylor Swift's the AAS tour for starters
Swift's partnership with sets a
precedent for concert films going
forward one that has already been
followed up by the other biggest female
pop act in the world Beyonce's upcoming
ambitious concert film Renaissance is
going to be distributed through AMC
theaters in a similar fashion according
to variety Beyonce negotiated directly
with AMC for the release of the filmed
version of her Renaissance World Tour
did the girls of Summer save the US
economy this doesn't just feel like the
way of the future for concert movies a
genre that has been increasingly
relegated to streaming platforms as the
years go on on in the wake of recent
labor tumult in the land of Hollywood
AMC is opening the possibility of
working directly with filmmakers and
creatives without the need for a studio
to act as a
distributor